is
[Silence]
commanded this fire to become
not only cool but
peaceful and gentle with
Ibrahim Alaihi Salam. The fire
obviously did as Allah
commanded it. Allah mentions
that the people of Ibrahim
tried to plot against him. And
so we made them the losers.
Meaning, because of their
plotting against Ibrahim
because of their, because of
their plotting and their
attempts on Ibrahim and his
life, Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
made them the made them the
losers. It says subhanahu wa
ta'ala and we delivered the
Ibrahim and Lut. Lot. To the
part of the earth that we had
made blessed for the creation
This is a reference to Hashem
It's mentioned that Iraq and
Luut originate both of them
originate from
Both of them originate from
from Babylon. Allah subhanahu
[Arabic recitation]
from there to
Palestine. and so it's
mentioned that Ibrahim Alaihi
Salam was in Palestine
and they are not very far from
each other. Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala then mentions that a
blessed and gave to Ibrahim as
an addition. To this blessing
of delivering him This hap and
Jacob Isaiah and Jacob, Jacob
is the son of Isaiah. They were
given to Ibrahim Alaihi Salam.
After Ismael, Ismael is older.
Ismael was
the first son of Ibrahim and
after him is Hak. Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala says and
each of them we made of the
righteous. And we appointed
them as leaders for the people.
They guide by our command. And
we sent revelation to them.
sent revelation to them,
commanding them to work
righteous deeds, establish
prayer, and to give and they
worshiped us and us alone. This
is a reference to Ibrahim
Alaihi Salam. It's a reference
to and Yakub. It's a reference
to and anyone who was with them
or part of them. Part of their
party and group We'll continue
tomorrow inshallah.